hello reject nation Greg Alva here I'm
John we are going to watch the vampire
launch trailer vampire you with why
before we do that there's a story
trailer that came out a month ago and I
feel like we should probably watch that
one first so we will get around to the
new launch trailer pretty much right
after it I have been playing video games
recently for the first time in years
played uncharted 1 and 2 The Last of Us
half I'm more than halfway through Red
Dead Redemption right now so I'm not at
the comfortable point yet to really like
start doing some actual gaming videos
and all that but I'm getting there guys
twit just for you guys
I'm loving it so let's watch the story
trailer first for vampire Genesis London
Cairo Magnus's video I just wanna know
rated and premature
[Music]
newly okay you made me who made me this
what are you
[Music]
I mean you no harm
like need help better call such a crude
word no you are now in a coma and that
you shall remain the previous symptoms
leading up to this attack were the same
indistinguishable from the epidemic look
we're something more file these
primitive
you
where's the money
Oh uniquely character to play the
shooters
the God everyone
you believe you disappointing a disease
Jonathan you we stand upon the precipice
what prevails in the end I wonder the
desire for blood or to be of service to
man need all right let's hop on to the
launch for the right away let's see what
we got here
let's see we got here we'll talk about
it
[Music]
the New England it must be appeased
the thing I become
[Music]
but soon to be hunted down like an evil
beast but as a doctor I know as Rustica
whoa Wow
Wow
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my life has become a waking nightmare I
did not choose the thing I've become but
I can't use the lives I now take just be
the choices
[Music]
is it vampire oh why because it's like
an upside-down cross or something I
don't know I mean there's no movie call
vamp here that spells it like that and I
am sure I think it's actually the
original spelling of vampire probably a
vampire genre is still one of my
favorite genres and like horror and one
time I like looked up vampires and I
think that was the original spelling
yeah I assume that this is my kind of
game notice like the games I've picked
up there all story based adventure
stories so far my favorite one and them
all has actually been the Last of Us
because I like the darker elements the
kick-ass graphics I'm the dark story
this is a cool approach because I feel
like I don't know enough about
videogames to determine whether or not
there's games where you play as vampires
what I do know is I picked up several
games where you're killing vampires it's
cool that you're gonna play as this
conflicted main character who is a
vampire who's probably gonna make some
pretty horrible mistakes and decisions
along this journey of being this guy and
is gonna get himself in a lot of trouble
while also taking on some bigger or
supernatural baddie element along the
way hard to keep up that Hippocratic
oath when you got a feed on people yeah
this looks totally cool and I'm just now
wondering like what the gameplay is
gonna be like like is it gonna be more
of like a puzzle oriented thing or are
you gonna have to go out and look for
people to feed upon or are you gonna
have to fight stuff looks like you're
gonna have to fight at least a couple of
things that's what I'm a wolf in that
whatever that big giant dude was I feel
like the gameplay will have this element
of you have a mission like a main
mission but then there's gonna be times
where he's hungry it's like when a
character needs rations or when a
character needs food and then he's gonna
have to go out there and find a specific
kind of human to kill so I wonder if
there's gonna be something where in the
beginning he like kills a innocent
person or - the guilt weighs down on him
so then he has to be more selective so
you actually have to like do some type
of side quest of fines there's all like
my theories on how the gameplay can go
down there you have to find like this
course is bad so yeah we can kill this
guy or maybe it's one of those games
where depending on who you
choose to feed upon the outcome of the
game changes because they will do
something that words like if you choose
a more moral or a less moral path you
know different things will happen
throughout the game and whatnot that
would be neat I feel like his powers
probably evolved over it because the
from the looks of it with the storage
try to come out of the launch is that
this will pick up right from the time he
discovers he's a vampire so you know you
won't want to feed and whatever and
realizes he can handle bullets and
whatnot he has this ability here where
he kind of just turns into a shadow like
wish it doesn't go bad blood dust thing
yeah yeah if that's a power you might
not get right at the beginning but
eventually strong I feel like this is a
neat idea it looks cool and I love the
setting to I love games that take place
in like you know period period
especially for me who's really been into
the Mike my girlfriend's introduced me
to show a penny dreadful them on the
second season right now the first season
deals heavily with vampires in London so
that to come off that show which I just
finished the first season only a couple
weeks ago to be seen this trailer is
like the perfect timing for me to be
watching this this is a lot of the world
my mind has been in in terms of like
imagination lately dude maybe there's an
unlockable Josh Hartnett that would be
sweet Oh commercial Green to play this
guy he's my go-to that is your go to a
new go to everyone has her Tom Hardy and
they're in trouble I get logo Marshall
green look-alike who have Tom Hardy yeah
I'm so proud of this moment right I just
like the amount of candor you taking on
over that guy you guys excited for this
game comes out in like a week or less
than that actually from the town we're
putting up this video it's at June 5th
right this is a few days from now yeah I
need a ps4 that's the problem that's
what we need to be splitting well I'm
trying to get I'm trying to get through
like the ps3 games I really want to play
and then upgrade to a ps4 because that's
where my like the story games I'm most
appeal to seem to be coming from yeah I
get that VR Resident Evil 7 pants
crapping lis terrified you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell you can check us
on patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is music video coverage would
love to have you become up a project
today